hallo deutsch schule punkt ch
hören und nachsprechen
[Musik]
lektion 28 hört zu und spricht nach
wie fährst du nach hause wie fährst du
nach hause
ich fahre mit dem bus ich fahre mit dem
bus ich nehme den bus ich nehme den bus
er fährt mit dem taxi
er nimmt das taxi er nimmt das taxi wir
fahren mit dem velo
wir fahren mit dem will wir nehmen das
velo
wir nehmen das will ich gehe
ich gehe zu fuß musst du noch ein
billett lösen musst du noch ein billet
lösen
der zug hat fünf minuten verspätung der
zug hat fünf minuten verspätung
ich löse ein billet nach davos ich löse
ein bild nach davos hast du ein halbtax
abo hast du ein halbtax abo ich sehe
mit den augen ich sehe mit den augen
ich rieche mit der nase ich rieche mit
der nase ich schmecke mit der zunge
ich schmecke mit der zunge
ich fühle mit der haut ich fühle mit der
haut ich höre mit den uhren
ich fühle mit den uhren
ich liebe mit dem herzen
ich telefoniere mit dem handy ich
telefoniere mit dem handy
zug
tram
[Musik]
bus
u bahn
zug tram bus u-bahn
ich steige an der nächsten haltestelle
aus
ich möchte ein billet lösen
ich möchte ein billett lösen
hast du schon ein beleg hast du schon
ein bild wo kann ich hier ein billet
lösen
wo kann ich hier ein billet lösen
entschuldigung wissen sie auf welchem
gleis der zug nach biel fährt
gleis der zug nach biel fährt wohin
hat dieses tram wohin fährt dieses traum
der bus hat fünf minuten verspätung
der bus hat fünf minuten verspätung hält
das tram beim museum hält das tram beim
museum wertes traum zum museum
wer das tram zum museum entschuldigung
wo ist die nächste bushaltestelle
entschuldigung wo ist die nächste
bushaltestelle
sie im taxi bieten sie
die bei der nächsten kreuzung rechts
abbiegen sie bitte
der nächsten kreuzung rechts ab fahren
sie langsam fahren sie langsam fahren
sie bitte vorsichtig fahren sie bitte
vorsichtig fahren sie schnell fahren sie
schnell ich habe es eilig ich habe es
eilig bringen sie mich bitte an die
zweig straße 5 bringen sie mich bitte an
die zwei straße 5 ich möchte zum bahnhof
bitte ich möchte zum bahnhof bitte ich
möchte zum flughafen bitte ich möchte
zum flughafen bitte lassen sie mich
bitte da vorne raus lassen sie mich
bitte da vorne raus
sehr geehrte fahrgäste wegen bauarbeiten
im tunnel lloyd verzögert sich die
ankunft des intercitys um zehn minuten
wir bitten um verständnis der intercity
kommt zehn minuten später
achtung achtung aufpreis 3 kommt der
schnellzug aus genf am bitte treten sie
zurück der schnellzug aus genf kommt auf
gleis 3
[Musik]
eine wichtige durchsage die s3 nach wien
vertäute auf geist auf kreis 5 achtung
die s3 nach wie fett nicht auf gleis 5
preis 5 ist heute wegen einer
leistungsstörung gesperrt die fahrgäste
der s 3 nach wil begeben sich bitte zum
gleis 9
liebe fahrgäste nächster haltloser
dieser zug fährt weiter ohne halt bis
genf fahrgäste mit ziel break bitte beim
nächsten halt in losem umsteigen
achtung achtung liebe gäste des
hauptbahnhofs zürich
der kleine stefan kuster sucht seine
mutter erwartet beim treffpunkt frau
erika kuster bitte kommen sie zum
treffpunkt des hauptbahnhofs jesu und
stephan wartet dort wie eine
begleitperson der sbb liebe fahrgäste
der zug kommt in wenigen minuten in
arosa am das ist unsere in station
wir bitten sie alle auszusteigen
der zug hat nachher ins depot bitte alle
fahrgäste in arosa aussteigen
danke
liebe fahrgäste der tgv nach paris fährt
planmäßig um 13 42 abbitte steigen sie
ein planmäßige abfahrt um 13 42
nächster halt physikum fahrgäste nach
rapperswil bitte umsteigen
diese s2 fährt weiter nach altendorf
lachen 7 wangen ziegelbrücke nächster
halt verfügung